good morning believe nation today's
message is do it for a reason over to
you notorious b.i.g whatever you go do
just do for a reason you know say don't
be the fool to this sit back and do it
cuz somebody else doing it because you
gonna do is follow me somebody else's
footsteps you just gonna be a shadow
won't be a shadow for the rest of their
life and I'll say if you got a little
something you know how to do if you look
at anybody who's had success in whatever
field they're in they've done it for a
reason it wasn't just trying to make
money it wasn't just trying to beat
somebody else it wasn't just trying to
make their parents and their friends and
somebody else happy and that that that's
the worst reason if you're doing
something just try to make your parents
happy your friends or somebody else's
expectations it never works out never
hit it big you're always playing small
because it's not your dream it's not
your goal do you have some success but
you'll have small success here where you
really should be killing it way over
here you have to have a powerful reason
and this is what separates you from
everybody else because your reason is as
unique as you are why you want to do
something is customized to yourself and
that's where you're gonna have the most
success by following the thing that gets
you excited by following a thing
that applies your reason to your
business your career path wherever you
end up going
I love entrepreneurs I believe in
entrepreneurs I'm doing it in my way I'm
creating and expressing how Evan
Carmichael creates an Express and as
long as I am true to myself nobody will
beat me because you can't out Evan Evan
and I can't out you you so you got to
find you because that's how you win if I
look at you and I can't tell the
difference between everybody else and
you all you're doing is following the
best practices and not modeling them and
not applying them and twisting them to
make it work for you and creating
something that hasn't existed before
then you're always gonna be a shell
you're always going to have minor wins
instead of big huge empire
Victory's and so I think that's really
important for any entrepreneur for
anybody really but for entrepreneurs to
find your reason that I understand why
you're doing this to ask yourself look
at yourself in the mirror why am I doing
this
and you better have a really good reason
and if you don't if you don't have a
really good reason for why you're doing
the thing you're doing that's why you're
not having any success if you're not
further ahead if you're not where you
want to be if you're not crushing on
your goals
I'd really examine your why and that's
yourself do what you have a really
strong reason to keep doing this because
if you don't you're never going to hit a
big so the question of the day today is
I'm curious what is your reason for why
you do what you do what is your big
reason leave in comments below I'm gonna
join the discussion I also want to give
a quick shadow to Harminder thank you so
much for picking up a cup of my book
your one word it really really really
really means a lot to me and I hope you
enjoy it so thank you guys again for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one where it is much love
and I'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot events best
miss Bristow keep me